death counts where are we everybody
coronavirus cases right now in the world
two million eight hundred thirty one
thousand seven hundred and eighty four
deaths 197 three hundred and six
recovered eight hundred and six thousand
nine hundred fifty three let's do it by
country we're about to break a million
in the USA tell them what they've won
they've won a Great Depression young
people are having strokes no one knows
why nobody knows you go to the hospital
you may not live this is a it's a brutal
sickness man even though I criticize
like the way the government's handled it
and we can all debate what's coming and
everything like that it is a real virus
like the people out there to think that
this is not real or mentally ill like
it's people are getting it and they're
dying I don't listen you may say you
might look at the numbers and go huh
those are worried me but that's fine and
you can make a judgment on the mortality
rate but like there are people in
hospitals right now checking out in
their 40s in their 30s and it's you know
you know in the USA there's some real
critical there's 15,000 critical cases
in the USA that doesn't seem like a lot
and it's not a lot but I also could be
the result of the fact that nobody's
been outside because once everybody
starts going outside you might see more
cases if China did this and they
introduced a vaccine and then we all
take the vaccine and then they flip on
the 5g switch and we all explode or we
all fall to the ground and start shaking
you got to give it to China you've got
folks folks you gotta give it to them
credit where credit is due
sometimes you got to know when you've
been beat
they're gonna win they're putting people
in in in in while they're still
screaming in in in in a crematorium and
then put them in an urn they're gonna
win here we're apologizing because we
said the wrong word they're gonna win
it's just a matter of when and if they
really did this and then the five G
starts being used and people just fall
to the ground and start shaking I mean
hats off to China I don't I don't want
to I don't want it to be the case but if
that is the case as so many of you
happen to believe then hey what are you
gonna do what are you really gonna do
all these people are going to work Trump
doesn't care about these people yeah he
doesn't he does it he's not gonna Obama
didn't I understand it's shitty to work
at a meat processing plant when this
pandemic is happening how fun was it
pre-pandemic to work at the meat packing
plant
what kind of barrel of fun was it
packaging meat before this for no money
let me know maybe I'm wrong maybe it was
a real ball everyone who's having at the
meat packaging plant before corona I
could be wrong meat needs to be packaged
people need to package meat I like me so
do you if we fire all that b-day this
comes down to the fact that not
everybody is going to there are people
out there that work at jobs that are not
there's no silver lining so their silver
lining is a ciggy or a glass of booze or
maybe a nice pill or the Lord Jesus or
you know darkweb torture porn or a nice
big Beaufort ooh checkers nice sloppy
Buford but the jobs not getting better
at the meat plant it's think about it
think about working it to meet plan it's
not nice it's not good everyone's like
them now workers that the meat by the
way did anyone give a [ __ ] about any of
these essential workers before they're
essential they're making $8 an hour
they're essential we've never treated
them like essential workers and I'm
saying that's [ __ ] up I'm saying
that's not good but we've never treated
them like it's a because let's be on it
if you're essential in a pandemic it
doesn't mean you're essential without a
pandemic and I'm I respect the [ __ ] out
of the grocery clerks that are out there
but it's it's you know it's a different
world now and you're now essential but
you weren't essential and it's insulting
you to pretend that we think you're
really we don't think you're really
essential I gotta be honest with you I'm
telling the truth
Susan Sarandon won't tell maybe she will
Saran is all over the place and probably
on pills and might say things it makes
sense occasionally but you know what I
mean that the the the the the people out
here in Hollywood and their pools
they're not gonna tell you the truth I'm
telling you the truth we don't really
think you're essential we just don't
want you to die I don't want to die and
I don't want you to die but we don't
think you're essential I'm we God if any
of us and I mean anybody had to work it
to meatpacking plant they would blow
their head off I'm just saying I'm not
insulting you at the plant I have to be
honest if you don't expect honesty from
me I don't know what I can give you
truly if you're not expecting honesty
here so let's cut the [ __ ] and this
canard about the essential work it's
it's great like all these celebrities
like it's the thank you bus drivers [ __ ]
one hey [ __ ] one
[ __ ] about Shriver make them essential
to your [ __ ] [ __ ] one of these people
that you say are essential take them
home
open your beautifully manicured snatch
to someone packing meat at the plant how
about that put your money where your
mouth is and put his mouth where your
mouth is or her mouth go grab a big
feisty Dyke at the Tyson chicken plant
and let her go down on you why not cuz
you're essential thank you
is there anything now I brought food
twice to the nurses and the doctors in
it and I immediately regretted it and I
paid once
Whitney paid the other time she's done
well uh and and the reality is this I
want I want the nurses in it but then I
realized they don't need food they don't
need me showing up with with baked ziti
they don't need me showing up with trays
of lasagna this isn't a retirement party
in a VFW hall in Long Island City er
they need other [ __ ] PPE vaccine listen
I'm all for helping people but like we
have to be honest now because if we're
not honest we're gonna we're going to
we're going to devolve rapidly into a
world where people are always lying at
everyone and that's gonna get us all
killed
sooner or later if we're not honest we
have to be honest you don't care about
the essential workers you can't flip a
switch and start caring about someone
overnight you truly do not care because
here's the thing some of these essential
work and I understand but some of them
still have attitudes I'll rip the mask
off your face
do you understand I said where's the
gravlax
the gravlax is different than the
regular smoked-salmon [ __ ] you know
this you know this the smoked salmon and
the brother gravlax is cured with the
dill don't treat me I will I'll grab the
mask off your face he's one of us okay
let's cut the [ __ ] I know that
everybody's treating you like you just
you know so let's cut it out I am all
for paying these people more [ __ ]
money but I'm not for these fake social
media displays of affection to strangeiy
don't care stop banging pots and pan yes
it is nice for a little while it is nice
I understand that but do we need deeper
structural change you know I know david
dobrik is going around la shooting a
t-shirt cannon at people and they're
making $10,000 that's lovely
but perhaps there needs to be a more
widespread effort at healing the wealth
divide that's so entertaining because we
live in a fallen world where you're you
know people's only hope now is that the
billionaire from YouTube shoots a
t-shirt cannon at them with ten thousand
dollars I was I thought he was just
going around la shooting people which I
supported and I said now now I get it I
get it I people I was like why this guy
so popular he's a cutie and he's nice
and I do like I do like about Nobby
Phillip but you know I was always said
likewise he said and then I looked they
go oh he's just running around any
shooting people and I go what I like and
I think there's something about that
he's embracing where we are and what
needs to be done they were going he's
going around and he's shooting families
in need and at that point I said well I
like that right he sees a family in need
he goes well they're a [ __ ] I don't
need for leeches get him out of here I
was like I'm in for that now but suppose
he's giving them money I don't like that
I don't like that but he's going around
to families in me this is American 2020
I want everybody to take a deep breath
and rush where America is in 2020
Americans
if you are a family in need in America
you can only rely on the YouTube guy
shooting you with a t-shirt cannon and
hope to god it has a check in it because
the government is is not-- we're no
longer a functional state that's where
we are that's not a joke that's not a
bit that's not a bit and and the
government will provide you nothing your
only hope is that you happen to be
walking around the same area as the
YouTube millionaire who's shooting ten
thousand dollar checks at you that's
charity in America he's gonna shoot a
potato gun and he's gonna bury a ten
thousand dollar check in a potato and
then shoot it at you that's that is
America right now and you trended on
Twitter for it I feel like he's the best
person it's ever lived and I have no I'm
not saying don't do charity but I'm
saying that's where we are I have to
step not everything can be about selling
sneakers which is my problem but
existing in the digital world because
that's literally everything here is just
about and we are launching a line of
something soon and I don't want don't
come at me and say well what about this
any of that you go [ __ ] your mother is
what that is because we're launching
something very soon it's gonna be very
good for everybody and and all of the
donations will go to Hollywood
celebrities who are already wealthy
because we're not throwing good money
after bad I'm telling you that families
in need why are you a family away from
me grows go get David go chase david
dobrik down the street maybe he'll shoot
you with it with it with her with a
t-shirt at him maybe there'll be a wet
t-shirt contest worth at the end of it
david dobrik he gives you 30 grand in
pennies and you have to crawl around the
street and stuff them in your ass it
doesn't matter but that's where we are
as a country and be happy be happy David
I'm not I'm not insulting him be happy
he's there I'm out of the money to do
that I don't know if the sponsors that
help me do that either okay I could I
guess I could fling Ridge wallets at
these families in need which by the way
I saw the videos
you know how I need these people were
people that are in need
you can't shoot something out in many
cases because they would shoot you back
I wish you shot something with ten grand
I would I was so yelling at him like
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do with 10
grand and LA go to lunch go to lunch